bleu
j'aimerais tellement parlé de moi alain
par tech comme étant que j'étais vivant
j'avais certes elle m'encourage
traitements utilisés
chapeau et pour toiser jamais l'accueil
car je suis nord
le gallon et sur le tour mais je suis
bien le ciel prend garde à toi
enfin
vous
j'aimerais tellement parlé le mois au
subjonctif comme de table j'étais sam
jackson pour tendre la main avec tous
trois plus de ballons j'ai venus des
universités
j'étudie la perdre la manne fonds se
recoucher elle me chatouiller le bien
car je suis à
chaud de galway sur le toit sinon
tu viens le ciel prend garde à toi
garde à toi
j'aimerais tellement parlé de moi à
l'unisson comme
j'étais manger des vampires et moment
j'étais
car je suis nord
j'aimerais tellement
oui mais tellement
ne plus parler de moi j'ai tout dit
parfois je ferais bien vous écouter on a
sali berisha
j'ai loupé un palois de mai aps le
revêtement comprendre le prix mais je
suis ballon intéressait
tué nord
show du galon et sûre de moi oui
je viens le ciel égard à bout